every dead character who stays dead in
the MCU is potential money that's
slipping through Disney's couch cushions
so when a hero or villain takes a dirt
nap you can rest assured there was a
solid reason for it and possibly one
that will have larger implications down
the road many spoilers ahead remember
the other in the Avengers this double
thumbed alien acted as a middleman
between Thanos and Loki in 2014's
guardians of the galaxy he's casually
murdered by an irritated Ronan the
accuser
the madman wants thanasis attention and
is frankly quite tired of the Titans
emissary barking at him I only ask that
you take this matter seriously no the
other isn't a major character though
fans of early Joss Whedon TV shows Buffy
the Vampire Slayer and Angel were
probably a little disappointed to see
him go the alien was played by Alexis
Denisof who played Wesley wyndam-pryce a
Buffyverse character initially so
annoying it's amazing no one ever broke
his neck excuse me in the 2018 prose
novel Thanos the Titan consumed by Barry
lega we learned that Ronan did more than
dispatch an annoying intermediary here
the other is a Chitauri specifically the
only Chitauri to be a bonafide
individual he negotiated Thanos taking
over the leadership of his people the
rest of the Chitauri share a hive mind
which is why they all died when their
command ship is destroyed in the
Avengers when Ronan kills the other it's
really a bit like finding the Holy Grail
and tossing it into an active volcano
of course Ronan is also a psychotic
maniac
[Music]
when Quicksilver was killed by ultron in
avengers age of ultron it was natural
for many viewers to assume the choices
made to forestall any confusion between
the MCU Quicksilver played by Aaron
taylor-johnson and the version of the
character introduced in Fox's x-men Days
of Future Passed played by Evan Peters
you didn't see that coming
not according to Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige who in 2015 told
MTV that Quicksilver died to elevate the
stakes of age of ultron and more
importantly to guide the future of his
sister Wanda played by Elizabeth Olsen
Feige told MTV the speedsters death
acted to solidify scarlet witch's
character and Wanda's arc in the movie
and where we'll see her in the next
films if Quicksilver had lived he maybe
would have had a thing or two to say
about his sister getting into her
relationship with an Android whichever
site Quicksilver would have chosen in
Captain America Civil War would have
likely impacted Wanda's choices she may
not have automatically sided with him
but Quicksilver support or lack thereof
could have affected her decision by the
time infinity war rolls around it's safe
to assume that the Scarlet Witch were
left with is one who is much more
independent
what exactly happened to the planets and
are in Avengers infinity war Thor
explains to the Guardians how Fanus and
his forces got the Power Stone there's
six stones out there Asano's already has
the power stone because he stole it last
week he decimated zonda decimated is a
powerful word but not a specific one did
he literally kill everyone on the planet
or ten percent of the planet for all you
that's not what decimation means people
do you know who you are one tantalizing
possibility we're going to see Xander
transformed into one of Marvel's
upcoming movies we may even see it's
Nova Corps grow closer to the source
material and guardians of the galaxy the
Nova Corps is made up of relatively
normal people in the comics it's a
different story every member of the
Corps has superpowers they're
essentially Marvel's answer to the Green
Lantern Corps
instead of rings they're given helmets
that grant them powers their abilities
aren't nearly as versatile as the
lanterns but at the same time there are
a whole lot less CGI than them as well
if Xander survived after weather and two
separate assaults by alien maniacs its
inhabitants may decide it's about time
they build an army capable of more than
just piloting spaceships and arresting
raccoons they might do whatever it takes
to found the real Nova Corps Kurt
Russell's eco identifies as a celestial
before his defeat at the end of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 this race
of mysterious beings has nearly
limitless power in the comics they even
hold the keys to many of the universe's
biggest mysteries that's one of many
ways eco differs from his comic book
counterpart who is literally a planet
with a giant planet sized face but
that's not the part that's particularly
meaningful about his death instead it
points towards one of the MCU franchises
we haven't seen yet we know Marvel
Studios is gearing up to introduce
audiences to the Eternals a race of
superhumans whose origins are very much
intertwined with these Celestials in the
comics the Celestials created the
Eternals specific
to defend the earth against their
opposite the deviance if the movie
characters remain true to the comics
it's likely we'll be learning way more
about the Celestials than we ever did in
guardians of the galaxy or any other
Marvel Studios films the fact that ego
was killed by an earth man could be of
great interest to Marvel's newest heroes
[Music]
he evidently believed he was the only
celestial in existence in Captain
America the Winter Soldier we learned
that Arnim Zola died years before while
secretly working with the freshly
resurrected terrorist organization Hydra
but Zola also sneakily transcribed his
memories and personality into data
the result is an exposition scene
outlining what Hydra had been up to for
70 years it's also a clever visual
tribute to the Arnim Zola of the comics
curiously there's something that's been
left completely unsaid in the MCU so far
for Hydra Arnim Zola artificial
intelligence had to have been an
important step down a very specific Road
in Avengers age of Ultron we learn a
piece of vital information during a
conversation between Bruce Banner and
Tony Stark about the possibility of
finally realizing their Ultron project
stark says his research on the sceptre
leads him to believe Hydra was using it
to develop an advanced artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence
this could be in person
this could be the key to creating Ultron
if stark is correct then the creation of
the Zola AI must have been part of the
research that ultimately leads to the
birth of Ultron and vision in fact fans
almost saw some persuasive evidence to
back up this theory in November 2016
some concept art for ant-man leaked and
it revealed that director Peyton Reed
considered bringing Zola back for the
prologue scene at the shield Triskelion
still under construction since ant-man
was the first film to follow up age of
Ultron it might have helped cement the
notion that Zola was in fact Ultron's
ancestor an Iron Man to Mickey Rourke's
character even Vanko also known as
whiplash swears vengeance on Tony Stark
that's because Ivonne was taught that
Starks father Howard stole the idea for
the game-changing arc reactor from his
father twice in the film we see a small
bit of evidence that seems to support
this design schematics with van Gogh's
name listed before Starks Nick Fury
employs an interesting strategy when
trying to rein in Starks
havior Patel Stark that Vanko was full
of it insisting that all of his claims
of stolen innovation could be chalked up
to his anger after being shipped off to
Siberia he spent the next 20 years and
vodka fuel rage but we never
definitively learn whether whiplashes
father's accusations were valid fury
says they weren't in the Avengers fury
also says that shield is only interested
in the tesseract because of the clean
energy it can provide and that's a big
fat lie
fury is far from a reliable source it is
curious that vanko's name came first on
the schematics both on the copies Vanko
has early in the film and the one stark
finds in the stuff shield brings him
from storage regardless will probably
never get to the bottom of this one
whiplash certainly didn't in Doctor
Strange the death of the ancient one
raises questions that aren't answered by
the end of the film and even though
Stephen strange appears in Thor Ragnarok
and Avengers infinity war those
questions still have yet to be answered
there are hints perhaps but nothing
concrete yet you know what we're getting
at here basically what exactly happened
to come our tosh immediately after the
Ancient Ones death
strange and Mordo head to Hong Kong by
the end of the film the Ancient Ones
death leaves a huge void in cartagia's
leadership and we have no idea who if
anyone has stepped up to fill it what do
you think about it the ancient one and
her students are apparently the only one
standing between the MC use earth and
hordes of malevolent forces so honestly
the question of who's steering the ship
now that she's gone seems like a pretty
important one to answer straightaway one
of the hints we get is dr. Strange's
conspicuous leap in terms of his mystic
skills and Doctor Strange he can barely
keep up with casillases henchmen but by
infinity war the guy gives Santos a
better one-on-one fight than just about
any other hero in the movie and that's
when Thanos has four Infinity stones
could it be possible that strange was
allowed to assume leadership of kamar
Taj and spite of being the new kid on
the block it's strange
baby watch a judge discuss amongst
yourselves want to know our vote for the
most surprising death in 2018 s Black
Panther it had to be when kill monger
played by Michael B Jordan kills ulysses
klaw - think I so used some crazy
American initially introduced as a
weapons dealer in the 2015 film Avengers
age of Ultron some fans thought Klaw
might be the main villain of Black
Panther and for very good reason for
quite a while Ulysses Klaw has not only
been the wakandan monarchs most
persistent foe he was actually two
challahs first enemy in the comics
Ulysses Klaw is much more than a thief
to a Conda he's the killer of a king
while trying to steal wakanda's
vibranium for himself it's Ulysses who
murders two challahs father - Chaka
still just a boy - Chawla shoots Ulysses
with his own sonic weapon causing him to
be transformed into the villain claw a
being composed of solidified sound Black
Panther director Ryan Coogler didn't
like killing off Klaw and made 2018 he
told the Toronto Sun I like claw it
really bugged me having to kill him it's
tough when you have to kill characters
off and I really did love that character
I'm sure that's gonna be okay I'm sorry
considering Kugler fondness for both
claw and actor Andy Serkis could we one
day see claw return as a villain that's
a little closer to the source material
it seems quite possible especially
considering it looks like koogler might
be willing to resurrect a certain
special someone for Black Panther to
just select kill you check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]